[Music]
science contains within itself this
necessity of externalizing the form of
the notion and it contains the passage
of the notion into consciousness
for the self-knowing spirit just because
it grasps its notion as the immediate
identity with itself which in its
difference is the certainty of immediacy
or sends Consciousness the beginning
from which we started this release of
itself from the form of itself as the
Supreme freedom and Assurance of itself
knowledge
in this short paragraph number 806 what
we're seeing is a consolidation very
very close to the end of the
phenomenology of spirit of what has been
going on in the absolute knowing section
up to this point and there are a few
things that I want to point out before
we jump right into a sequential reading
of the passage one is that you notice
Hegel is going to talk about
sense Consciousness how it's translated
here is that the same thing as the very
very beginning of the Consciousness
section where we're just seeing the raw
objects so to speak and then we go
through and and start to examine it
I I don't think so even though he does
talk about a beginning an onfong I think
we should read this through as sort of
sensuous Consciousness
is the German here so
Consciousness that is working through
the medium but perhaps not completely
restricted
to the
[Music]
medium that it's working with that is of
the senses right so there's an opening
but also a reduction going on so let's
hold that for a moment the other thing
is that he talks about a release and
Lawson
of itself Zina from the form of itself
Zina zelps right and we can ask
ourselves well what is the referent here
right this release of itself from the
form of itself he tells us is supreme
freedom and Assurance of itself
knowledge and we'll get to that so we
have a couple different candidates right
the passage Begins by talking about
science this and shaft and we have the
notion coming up over and over again or
the concept of and then we have
self-knowing spirit and then we have a
sense Consciousness which is the actual
itself in this case I I think the best
candidate is actually self-knowing
spirit because that is carrying through
this and connected to
knowledge
knowing itself right ultimately in the
form of science which is what we're
trying to transition to
but you know let's come back to that in
just a moment let's begin here now at
the beginning so you invoke science
which he's referenced several times
Houston shaft right not merely a
phenomenological approach to things but
something that is in some ways more
robust as we saw in the previous
paragraph right
so he says science contains within
itself so and health it includes
um in itself you know in Zeke several
different things and one of these is a
necessity at note vindicate this is
going to be important when we look at
the next paragraph where instead of
talking about necessity we see
contingency coming up a necessity of
what of the form of the notion the big
the concept however we want to translate
but Griff
externalizing and poison right itself
this is a constant theme throughout here
alienating is another way this is
sometimes translated
externalizing the form of the notion
right but it also contains a passage an
Uber gang going over literally
sometimes ubagang means something like a
thing disappearing or transmuting into
something else in this case is the
notion going away no but there there is
a passage a movement to use a term that
hagel's been using over and over again
of the notion that because if into
Consciousness but Voice sign right so
you know in this this uh
particular paragraph It's just
Consciousness it's not
self-consciousness that is being brought
up but of course I and all that's past I
think we have to read that in especially
since we're talking about self-knowing
Spirit right there's all of these selfs
involved in this right a release from
the form of itself so the Consciousness
yes it is consciousness but also
self-consciousness at the same time
which is being reconciled with
Consciousness so
science contains these two moments
within itself a necessity of the form of
the notion externalizing itself and a
passage of the notion into Consciousness
are these radically distinct from each
other
they're going hand in hand right the
externalization and the passage both are
bearing on the notion and so
externalizing itself for consciousness
all right so so far so good
then he goes on he says for the
self-knowing spirit right the Geist that
knows vicinda itself
um just because it grasps its notion so
it it now is at the point where it
understands or it conceptualizes its
concept you could say so the the notion
is showing up here quite a bit now this
is
its notion but you know its notion is as
we've seen we could think about this
a little bit you know going back to the
previous paragraph where we saw this
parallelism between what's happening
from a phenomenological point of view
running throughout the entire
phenomenology into absolute knowing and
what is happening in science this and
shaft uh science works with Notions and
the notion of the self-knowing spirit
right
um we could say is actually a
stage
right or a shape of Consciousness what
shape of Consciousness absolute knowing
the section we're in the final shape
right so that is the the form that that
spirit is taking on right now and he
tells us a few things about this so he
tells us the self-knowing spirit is the
immediate un mitsubar identity like
height with itself which in its
difference now isn't it interesting to
see this so two different terms that
I've brought up a lot already right so
we need to be careful with these glycite
identity works
equivalence
uh maybe if we want to think about it a
little bit more dynamically in terms of
the Lichen rather than merely glyc
height the uh you know sort of
identifying or becoming identical with
we're going to talk about becoming in
the next paragraph as well so maybe
there's something to that
um you know so glyph height doesn't just
mean identity like equals but it can
mean something a little bit uh more
robust and then uh difference right
literally things being separated from
each other so even in an immediate
identity there's also a difference here
difference of what
so he says in its difference
it is the certainty of immediacy the
bovous side of uh when metal bar the the
immediate right or sense Consciousness
the beginning from which we started I
mean it would be tempting again to say
all right we're all the way back here at
the very beginning not the even the
introduction or the preface but sense
certainty right we just mentioned that
but again I think we have to read this a
bit broader we're not just you know
we're not just going around in a circle
right
um people are often attracted to that
but it's more like a spiral for Hegel we
we Ascend that way so we get so sense
Consciousness right
what does that lead us to this final uh
sentence here the this release of itself
from the form of itself is what Supreme
Freedom so freiheit
okay that's important necessity and
freedom here are being reconciled and
Assurance
so freedom is is good
is even better in a certain respect
because it means we hold on to what
we've actually achieved through all this
dialectical process we're going to see
that really being Consolidated in the
final paragraph
um less so in this paragraph 807 that
follows but he says the Supreme freedom
and Assurance of
it's self-knowledge of its knowledge of
what it is in relation to not only
itself as Consciousness but
self-consciousness the rest of the other
self-consciousnesses but now in the form
of
science
yet this externalization is still
incomplete it expresses the connection
of its self-certainty with the object
which just because it is thus connected
has not yet won its complete freedom
the self-knowing spirit knows not only
itself but also the negative of itself
or its limit
to no one's limit is to know how to
sacrifice oneself this sacrifices the
externalization in which Spirit displays
the process of its becoming spirit in
the form of free contingent happening
intuiting its pure self is time outside
of it and equally as being as space
this last becoming of spirit nature is
its living immediate becoming nature the
externalized spirit is in its existence
nothing but this eternal
externalization of its continuing
existence and the movement which
reinstates the subject
in paragraph 807 we reach the
penultimate paragraph of this entire
absolute knowing section and because
that is the last section of the
phenomenology of spirit we are at the
second to last paragraph of the entire
work and you know the first couple times
that you read it you might feel a little
bit of a letdown in part because you
know it's full of Hegel jargon what's
going on here we'll talk about that in
just a moment but also because it seems
like we're not really getting at what we
wanted in the end which is this sort of
like vision of the totality in a
conceptual
medium uh you know bringing the entire
phenomenology to a close preparing the
way to move into the realm of science
it seems almost as if we're taking a
detour unless you look at the very last
sentence of this which we'll talk about
but notice how it begins
um this externalization
is still incomplete it hasn't been
brought to its fruition unfolland it
right and you might say well that's okay
we still have one paragraph left well
there better be an awful lot happening
in that final paragraph if this
externalization is not yet completed it
says it expresses the connection
right of its self-certainty subscribe
with the object which just because it is
thus connected has not yet won its
complete freedom and what hasn't won its
complete Freedom the object no the
self-certainty the what sort of
self-certainty the self-certainty of
spirit as we saw in the previous
paragraph and there's going to be an
interesting shift on Miller's part in
terms of what's actually being said in
the German and what he reports in his
translation in just a second but let's
think about this so connection of
self-certainty with the object that it
is connected to so there's a connection
upbearing on connection right and solve
certain Spirit does have objects we're
going to see these objects are actually
mentioned a little bit later on time
space and nature we'll get to that so
then Miller says the self-knowing spirit
knows not only itself but also the
negative of itself or the limit
now does he say the self-knowing spirit
knows that no he actually says dasvism
right but
that's okay because what is doing this
knowing what is knowing itself
self-knowing Spirit okay so that's
that's clear enough
now we get to something really
interesting so it knows the negative of
itself this is the object that it's
knowing
the limit the glenza
the Border we could say the space after
which it's something else
now
if you've read the science of logic or
at least the very beginnings of it you
know that Hegel plays around
with this notion of limits and there's
kind of a paradoxical
framing in this insofar as whatever you
want to call it Consciousness spirit
can conceive of a limit
it's already in a certain way
beyond that limit
really you know in vehicle Heights or
reality not necessarily
but the mere Act of posing a okay this
is as far as we can go already
posits something Beyond it and you could
say well you know that's because there
is something Beyond it well how the hell
do you know if you haven't crossed that
limit
or maybe it's empty Beyond it well how
the hell would you know that right
Hegel is actually on to something quite
deep here that he's just gesturing at
not getting into depth in but there's
something really strange happening in
how it actually
knows its negative this this limit how
does it know it
well Hegel tells us
that knowing the limits means knowing
how to sacrifice
of open
to make a sacrifice to make an offering
you could say
of itself
the sacrificing to what
there's I mean if you think about it is
there some sort of like greater
Eternal truth capital S spirit that like
our little Spirits sacrifice them to
that that's a picture of Hegel that we
sometimes do get in some Works don't we
summarizing what Hagel is doing and
sometimes he does talk as if the
individual
sacrifices themselves to the community
or the you know religious point of view
or the state or whatever it's going to
be
but this is Spirit itself can Spirit
sacrifice itself to something else
I mean maybe it could sacrifice itself
too as we see mentioned nature
but that would be a step backwards
because nature as we're going to see
is kind of a a realm that by itself is
not
meaningful right we actually wanted to
play on the word Zin right nature is
grasp sensuously right but it's not
grasped as full of Zin meaning except
locally in terms of you know desires
impulses reproduction that sort of thing
but what we're looking for here is the
absolute
so how do we get this the absolute
through self-knowing spirit
knowing its limit and then knowing how
to sacrifice itself well this
sacrificing itself this is we can
understand that in terms of
externalization right and oil a term
that we've been using a lot we can also
understand it in terms of becoming
vaderden which is going to be important
in the second half of this paragraph and
in the start of the final paragraph
where Hegel is going to introduce a
different additional more important
viardin or becoming right
so what we're getting here
is
becoming a process of transformation
right so he says the sacrifice is the
externalization in which Spirit
displays the process of becoming
spirit it's becoming Spirit but how
well
in the form of free contingent happening
so free fry right that's good
um and we saw that it was referenced
just in the previous paragraph freiheit
you know freedom
contingent zopheliga okay well that's
not great here right the contingent the
just happens to be the case where's the
necessity whereas the note vindicate
that we were seeing just a little bit
earlier reference that we've been you
know seeing drive this entire process an
unfolding of necessity
um this seems to be a problem Spirit
becoming spirits
in the form of free contingent and then
this kind of consolidates it happening
geshans things that just you know wind
up being the case
and
what we're missing here to look ahead is
the dimension of geshikta History not
just kashan but the things that happen
to be the case that turn out this way or
that way
so following this out right we can say I
mean it's tempting actually when you
read this passage again to say aha
there's three different viardins going
on three different becomings but really
two of them are I would say subsumed
under what appears to be the third which
is encompassing them
and well I'll I'll hold on to that until
we get to the the very end of this
development so he says
um
it intuits its pure self as time outside
of it so itself
what is the self here the self of
spirit that has externalized itself
so we can see this as the
self-consciousness of everyone who's
managed to follow along up to this point
uh it externalizes itself as time time
is something that we are in but it can
also be understood as something that
lies outside of the self itself right
and notice that he uses the word pure
Reina right the pure self not the
individual self not the messy self of
um somebody existing in history formed
by their
society reacting within those Dimensions
but the you know
I mean you could read this as the
transcendental ego couldn't you so
there's that side self as time
pure selfish time and then pure being
Zine as space space and time this
suggests to us again what we just saw in
the previous paragraph
um sensible consciousness
um we exist in space and time we exist
through space and time space and time
are objects for us but also not just
objects but rather the we can say the
condition for the possibility of having
objects yes there's other stuff as well
but you better have those as kind of
call them forms of Intuition or else you
got nowhere to put objects know when too
right
and then Hinkle goes on and he talks
about nature he says
this last becoming of spirit nature
is it's living immediate becoming right
so
um life as we saw now this is
interesting because if we are tempted to
go back to the Consciousness section to
set certainty with these two
um life where does life first enter in
other than you know like looking at a
tree but not looking at a tree is a
living object
in the self-consciousness section
that's where Hegel Begins the
self-consciousness section
and we do have a few places where we
have kind of a reversion think about
like you know the spiritual animal
kingdom where we have this you know very
impressive uh panoply of different kinds
of life right well that so nature is
living
and
um it's an immediate when mythal virus
becoming Verdin and then he tells us two
things about this nature the
externalized spirit right so
nature here's what I was going to say
before nature is perhaps the limit that
we're talking about here Spirit knowing
itself in relation to its limit that it
externalizes itself and nature is you
know Nature's where Spirit exists
in its actual vehicle it could form
doesn't it I mean human beings
are spirit is Spirit reducible to Nature
we're going to see no
but
it's not radically sundered from it
nature the externalized spirit he says
is in its existence nothing but
this external
Eternal sorry avika externalization of
its continuing existence now continuing
existence there is a translating
a particular modality of being we could
say and it's also he says a movement
that reinstates her steth place is there
the subject
who's the subject again self-knowing
Spirit us the phenomenologist following
along
so nature can be understood in two
complementary ways
one way is that it's just this eternal
external
Eternal externalization of this
continuing existence that is like a
circle right just keeps on happening and
what happens is you you could say it has
local meaning but it doesn't have any
lasting or Global meaning right
but nature brings forth the subject
there's an opening in nature for what
has externalized itself through nature
but isn't reducible to Nature and this
is going to lead us into the final
paragraph where we see in the very first
line
Hegel brings up
history
and so this is a good place to
close off these Reflections to take a
little pause before we jump right into
that massive
final hopefully bringing it all together
it actually does I can tell you but
perhaps you don't know that paragraph of
the phenomenology of spirit